[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
42 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Compoy and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hello, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK: I'm good.
How are you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC: I'm, as
always, very happy.
MARK: Very happy.
You are always very happy.
You're a very chipper person.
FRANCESC: Yeah.
Especially after a long
weekend, extra happy.
MARK: Yeah.
FRANCESC: And also
happy because we
have someone, actually a
principal engineer at Google,
that is going to tell
us about security
and specifically
about encryption.
MARK: Yeah, it's a
really interesting topic.
FRANCESC: Yeah.
I think that the most important
thing about encryption,
like my most important
thing that I learned
during the interview,
was basically
you don't need to know what
you're doing because we do it
for you, which is good.
MARK: Which is good.
And that's basically
how I like to do things.
FRANCESC: Yeah, because
otherwise, like, what?
Private-- no, I don't want to
handle private keys, thanks.
So very interesting interview.
MARK: Absolutely.
FRANCESC: I'm sure
you will like it.
And at the end--
MARK: Yeah, we have our
usual question of the week.
We go back to something
pretty normal, pretty basic.
What options are available
for serving static content
on Google Cloud Platform?
FRANCESC: Yeah, like, I
want to run-- I have just,
like, HTML, CSS, JavaScript,
I want to serve that.
How do I do that?
So yeah, and that
will be at the end.
But now we're going to
start with the cool things
of the week.
I decided we'd--
MARK: Yes.
FRANCESC: --just rename it.
MARK: It's already been renamed.
FRANCESC: Done.
So the first thing is
something that I've
been pretty involved with.
And I'm very excited that we
have a public beta finally.
And it is Google
Cloud Endpoints.
MARK: Yeah, do you
want to tell us
about what that does, since
you've been so involved?
FRANCESC: Sure.
So Google Cloud Endpoints--
there was actually already
a thing called Google
Cloud Endpoints
that allowed you to serve
REST APIs, REST endpoints,
from App Engine.
Just that, and just
for Java and Python.
MARK: OK.
FRANCESC: Now what
we're doing is actually
making it a full-fledged feature
of Google Cloud Platform,
so your backend could still be
Java or Python on App Engine,
but it could be also
anything else, basically.
You can write on Compute
Engine or on Container Engine,
and with any language you want.
So yeah, the only requirement
is that you need to use Swagger,
and that is something that
we might add more languages
to describe your API, but to
start with, we have Swagger.
Which, if you have not
checked, basically it
allows you to describe your
API from a pretty high point
of view, but with enough
detail that then you
can generate the client
libraries very easily, which
is something very useful,
and that is actually
why the Google Cloud Endpoints,
the original one on App Engine,
was created.
On top of that, it makes
authentication easier.
It makes managing
API keys, so if you
want to give access to
people to your APIs,
but up to some quotas and stuff
like that, all of those things
become much easier because,
again, you don't really
have to manage them.
We allow you to use
Firebase authentication--
Auth0 authentication.
So basically it makes
managing REST endpoints
point much easier.
MARK: So I don't have to do
nearly as much work for just
doing regular REST endpoints.
FRANCESC: Yeah, it's much easier
to manage different versions,
to see what's going on,
you add some monitoring.
So yeah, it makes
it much, much easier
for anyone that is serving
REST APIs to third parties.
And I feel like this
deserves, maybe, an episode.
MARK: I think it does.
FRANCESC: Yeah, so we should
definitely do an episode,
and let's do it soon.
But in the meanwhile, there's a
second cool thing of the week.
MARK: Oh my god,
this is so exciting
because it involves cucumbers.
FRANCESC: Yeah.
I really didn't think
that I could end up
talking about cucumbers in
this podcast, but, you know.
MARK: I like cucumbers.
But it's all about how a
Japanese cucumber farmer is
using Deep Learning and
TensorFlow to basically sort
the good cucumbers from
the bad cucumbers, which
I think is fantastic.
FRANCESC: It is amazing.
And the really cool thing
is that you can actually
see, on the block post,
you can see pictures
of the different
classes of cucumbers,
and how there is the small
ones, the large ones,
but also depending on the
curvature, and the shade.
MARK: The color, yeah.
FRANCESC: So there's a lot
of different qualities.
And it is really cool
because it reminds me
of the classification
problem, where you basically
just try to recognize
handwritten numbers,
but with cucumbers.
And it's pretty amazing.
MARK: It is really cool.
I think my favorite
part is actually
that he took the MNIST--
FRANCESC: Yeah, MNIST.
MARK: Yeah, which
I believe is kind
of like the "hello world"
for these kind of problems,
and just kind of tweaked it.
I mean, I don't want to say a
little bit, but he tweaked it
and he modified it
from the example
that he was originally
given, to be
able to do this thing
with cucumbers, which
I think is super, super cool.
FRANCESC: Yeah, and
the end result here
is this machine where
you put cucumbers inside
and then it classifies
them in different buckets
according to the shape, size,
and quality of the cucumbers,
which is amazing, really.
MARK: Yeah, that's
super, super cool.
Awesome.
Well, why don't we go
have a chat with Umesh
and talk about
encryption and security?
FRANCESC: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK: Sounds good.
FRANCESC: So I'm very happy
to introduce Umesh Shankar.
Hi, Umesh.
How are you doing?
UMESH: Good, good.
I was actually looking at
my bucket list this morning,
and I only had two items left.
So now I've crossed
off the GCP Podcast.
All I have to do is climb
Kilimanjaro and I'm done.
FRANCESC: Easy.
That sounds like--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK: No worries.
FRANCESC: So before
we start talking
about the main topic
of the interview,
why don't you tell us
a little bit about you?
What do you do at Google?
UMESH: Sure.
Yeah, I've been at Google
for just over 10 years now.
Just hitting my 10-year
anniversary back in August.
And I've been working in the
area of security and privacy
engineering pretty
much that whole time.
I worked on a bunch of
products over that period.
I worked on Google Health
early on-- rest in peace.
And since then, I've spent a lot
of time building infrastructure
for protecting user data.
So that's things around crypto
key management-- something
we're going to talk a little
bit about today, I guess--
around authorizing and
authenticating requests,
both for external
access to user data
and, actually, also
how we protect user
data against
Googlers themselves,
and more technologies around
protecting binaries that
run in our production
network, all of which
actually play a part in how we
secure Google Cloud Platform.
So I'm really excited to talk
about that stuff with you
guys today.
MARK: Sweet.
That all sounds super,
super interesting.
Well, why don't we take sort
of a practical viewpoint.
Like say, OK, let's look at it
like I'm a classic developer.
Maybe I run, I don't
know, a GC instance,
like a virtual machine instance,
that has a web server on it,
and I'm going to go
access some data.
How does GCP security
and encryption--
how does that help
me from the requests
coming in through to
accessing the data?
Start at the top-- what happens?
UMESH: Yeah, that's
a great question
because I think what's different
about some of what we're
talking about today than some
of the previous podcast topics
is that we're talking
about a little bit more
of what goes on under the
hood versus the external
developer-facing part of GCP.
So one of the things
that GCP offers
is the ability to store data.
And we want to make
it safe for you
to store even sensitive data.
So in your hypothetical scenario
where you have a web server,
some of the content
you might be serving
could be private-- might
not be all public content.
And you really
want to be careful
that that data is
protected at rest,
meaning, like, when it's
stored in some system.
And we offer a variety of
storage products in GCP
that let you do that.
So Cloud Storage is
a classic example.
Now, the way that systems
like Cloud Storage
are actually implemented
tends to be these big software
stacks.
It's not just, like, one process
in a disk somewhere, right?
It tends to be a whole set of
different pieces of software.
So you send your request
to an API like the GCS API,
and you make a request to,
say, read or write piece
a piece of content in a bucket.
And that goes through a lot
of different processing.
So we decide, like,
OK, well, who are you?
Are you allowed to
do this operation?
What's your quota like?
We have to do building,
we have to figure out
where that data is located.
We probably have it replicated
in a bunch of different places.
And so all that happens
through a sequence of servers
that the request touches.
A lot of it's built on our
own internal infrastructure,
and even that tends
to have layers.
So we'll have our own
internal storage API,
and below that, we'll have
a low-level thingy that
manages the disks, right?
And so in the course of
this request being served,
a lot of different
things happen.
And we actually use different
kinds of security technologies
at every level of that stack.
So at each hop, as one
service talks to another,
we transmit information on
who is making the request,
and we try to use strong
forms of authentication
to make sure we know
really who that was
and that we're
not just guessing.
We also use, extensively,
access controls.
So we say, all
right, you're trying
to make a request to GCS.
We check your IAM policy, for
example, to say, OK, yeah,
were you allowed to do that?
But even internally to Google
when that service talks
to another service, we
make sure that data only
flows along correct paths for
specific kinds of requests.
At various points in the
stack, we use encryption.
And encryption is something
that we throw around
a lot because it's this
really important tool
in our toolbox for security,
but it is still just a tool.
And one of the most
important things
that encryption lets
us do is it lets
us reason about what
parts of the stack
we trust to do what things.
So if you think about
this deep software stack
where data is flowing down
and data is flowing up,
ideally, you don't
want to fully have
to trust all layers of the stack
with access to all the data.
And so what you can do at
some layer is say, OK, I'm
going to encrypt the data
before I put it in the lower
layer, and that
way, I don't have
to fully trust that
lower layer of the stack
because all I can see
is the encrypted data.
I don't have to worry
as much about exposure
via administrative controls
or via bugs or hacks
or whatever it might be.
And
So this is one
way that we employ
what we call defense in depth.
We have multiple layers
of encryption that we do,
whether it's at the
storage API level.
We also do it again at
the physical disk level
so that even if there is
a bug or a problem at one
level of the stack, we tend
to have more layers of defense
so that the chance that your
data will ever be in the clear
or actually be exposed is
reduced as much as possible.
FRANCESC: Cool.
So basically what that means
is that the lower levels don't
get to see your actual data.
Does that mean that as a
Google Cloud Storage user,
should I encrypt my data, or
does that happen automatically?
UMESH: Yeah, that's
a great question.
I think it really
depends on your use case.
And I think some
amount of history
is probably useful to
talk about at this point.
About 2007-2008,
we really embarked
on this big project, which
we called our data protection
effort.
And one of the first
things we built
is what we call a key
management system,
so that lets you provision
cryptographic keys
and use them to do
things like encrypt data
at rest, among lots of other
applications you might do.
And so we built this
thing, and we said,
hey, we have some
applications that have
really, really sensitive data.
Let's use this key
management system
to access encryption
keys, encrypt some data,
and just how we talked about,
reduce the amount of trust we
have to [INAUDIBLE]
in other parts
of our system and our platform.
And so we did that,
and it turns out
that managing keys is
really a lot of work.
For the average
application developer,
having to think about stuff like
what kind of keys should I use?
What encryption
mode should I use?
When should I rotate keys?
When should I re-encrypt data?
All these kind of questions
that come up on an ongoing basis
is just really, really painful.
And they'd rather just focus
on application logic, right?
I mean, that's kind
of a philosophy
that we bring to all of
Cloud Platform, right?
We want you not to have
to worry about a lot
of routine maintenance
reliability kind of tasks
and let you focus on the things
that you really want to do,
right?
What's the really
differentiating thing
about your app?
So after trying this kind of
everyone-for-themselves kind
of strategy, we
realized we needed
to have a more
integrated solution.
And so what we did is we did
a really big project to build
in encryption at rest,
and at the same time,
a bunch of other strong
operational security
controls to all our
core storage offerings.
So a lot of these have
now made their way
into GCP-- things like
Big Table and Spanner
and things behind GCS, as well.
And by integrating those
deep security features
like encryption, like
we actually verified
binaries so we know exactly
what code and configuration is
running in our
production network that's
ever allowed to touch keys.
That's really important
because then we
can trace that all the way
back to our source code system.
We have auditing controls
in the rare instances where
a person ever needs to
touch the sensitive material
for debugging, for example.
We have audit logs
of all that stuff.
So that kind of stuff we
kind of built all of a piece,
and what that let
us do is say, OK,
if you're a regular
application developer, which
is to say like most
application developers--
Google has a wide
variety of teams
making a wide variety
of applications-- a lot
of that work is not something
you need to actively worry
about anymore.
You just use the core storage
and you get all those features
for free.
That said, there
are still some cases
where we'll want
to do more or they
have somewhat different needs.
So examples would
be things like you
need to send data externally.
So you need to send a piece of
encrypted content out to a user
or to a partner
or something else.
Cases like that,
just having exception
at rest that's hidden by storage
isn't good enough, right?
You need to agree
on what kind of keys
you're using, what the encrypted
data formats look like,
and you can transmit
it to somebody else
or send it out there and then
get it back and interpret
the data.
So that would be one
example of a case
where you'd want
to do it yourself.
In some other examples, just the
nature of your infrastructure
is different.
Like, it doesn't look
like regular storage.
You want to do something
with a custom kind of index,
for example.
And those are also cases
where you might need
to manage your own encryption.
But those cases we found are
relatively few and far between,
and they do have really
large teams that are actively
staffed to manage that stuff.
So my expectation would be that
people using Cloud Platform
are going to follow a
similar distribution.
That most people should
be able to just rely
on the very strong security
guarantees that we give you,
but that there is
going to be people who
have particular
requirements, or maybe they
have that driven by compliance
or external compatibility,
for example.
And in those cases, people may
want to manage their own keys.
Or in the most
extreme cases, people
might want to say,
look, you guys at Google
are great and everything,
but, you know,
my stuff is super,
super sensitive.
I'm willing to invest
a lot of effort.
I don't want Google to ever
see the plaintext data.
And that's fine, too.
There are people that use
Cloud Platform in that way.
And it's something
that we want to do,
is give people a
spectrum of options.
So another option between
those two extremes
is actually a feature that we
launched with Compute Engine
and Cloud Storage called
customer-supplied encryption
keys, where you can actually
generate the key on your own
and supply it along
with your API call,
but Google will take care of
the actual mechanics of doing
the encryption for you.
MARK: Basically,
encryption is a continuum.
UMESH: Yeah.
FRANCESC: Maybe this is
the name of the episode.
Who knows?
OK, so in a nutshell,
basically what we have is
we can go from I
don't do anything,
and I get protected
because there
is all of those
mechanisms implemented
behind the curtains.
But at the same time, if
I need more protection
or I want to have something
more specific because I have
my own needs, there's
also the possibility
of implementing that.
Cool.
MARK: OK, so that's really cool.
It sounds like we have
a variety of options.
So if I have like,
I don't know, I just
want to put my photos up
there and I don't really
care who sees them, I can
do that really easily.
But if I've got something that
I don't want the world to see,
I can do that, as well.
But I suppose it's worth sort
of digging into it, as well.
So it's great that
GCP does encryption,
and encryption standards
are there for you,
and you're able to, kind of,
pull and push them in the ways
you want.
But how does that really
fit into the whole security
big picture?
Like, is this just
all I need to do,
or do I need to worry about
more things other than that?
We talked a little bit
about authentication.
Where does that fit in?
UMESH: That's a
really good question.
So as we talked about
earlier, encryption
is not a silver bullet.
It is a tool, and it's a tool
that, if you use it properly,
can really improve
your security story.
So it might be worth just
stepping back for a second
and saying, what
do you actually get
from using cryptography
in the sense
that we care about it for GCP?
The two properties that
people most look to crypto for
are called confidentiality
and integrity.
So confidentiality is what
people mostly think of,
which is if something
is encrypted,
then unless you
have the key, you
can't figure out what it is.
There are actually very
strict, rigorous definitions
of exactly what that means,
but more or less, that's
the intuition.
The other thing that you
want to get is integrity.
And integrity is
about making sure
that the data can't
be changed unless you
have a particular key.
And those two things--
actually, sometimes you
might think they're the
same, but they're not.
There actually
are crypto systems
where you can have
great confidentiality--
sort of under certain
reasonable assumptions,
no one can know what the
encrypted data actually relates
to as far as the clear data.
But it is also possible to
change that in such a way
that it has a
predictable result.
So if I encrypted
a number, someone
could change it in a way
that when I decrypt it,
I actually got twice the
original number, even
though they didn't know
what that number was.
So it is important to do
things in a careful way
that you get both
confidentiality and integrity,
and that's the best
practice, and that's
something that we strive to do.
And people who are
really interested
in the very particulars of
the details of how GCP does
these things, by the
way, should definitely
check out the white
paper that we recently
released, talking in quite a
bit of detail about exactly
where we employ what types
of encryption and what modes
and what kind of data is covered
and all that kind of stuff.
So please do check that out.
So anyway, to come back to
the basic purpose of crypto
and how it relates
overall security,
one way that I like to
think about using encryption
of data at rest is it
gives you a long lever
for access control.
What I mean by that
is a lot of times,
you're managing a really
large amount of data.
And there are certain
things you can
do with a small
amount of data that
are not as easy or
practical or efficient to do
with a lot of data.
And what you get with
crypto is you can say,
all right, none of
this data is accessible
unless I have this key.
So if I'm able to
protect the key, which
I can do lots of special
or sophisticated things
to protect that
key, that's actually
equivalent to protecting this
much larger amount of data
that it may not be
as practical to do
those same techniques with it.
So examples of the kind
of things you can do
are things like keep
keys only in RAM
so you don't ever
persist them, and that
gives you a certain
measure of protection.
So if, like, power
goes off, keys
are gone-- that's kind
of a nice property you
might want to have.
You can use very special
machines that are really,
really locked down,
and they're only
for this special purpose of
doing high-security operations
and managing keys.
You can't really do
that for all your data
because at that point,
you're not really
locking it down at
all if everything's
within that same boundary.
You can have a dedicated
team of security specialists
that manage just the key
infrastructure and just
the libraries,
and you can really
focus a lot of your effort
of making those really good,
which, again, is
hard to scale to pay
that much attention, that amount
of care, to every single thing
that you do.
So you can kind think
of crypto as a lever.
And if you really are careful
about who can access the keys,
that gives you a certain
measure of confidence around
who can access that much
larger amount of data.
But it doesn't solve all
your problems, right?
It doesn't solve the problems
of, for example, auditing
is another tool
that we like to use.
[INAUDIBLE] It is
the case that, like,
a person may need to
access a piece of data
for administrative or
debugging purposes.
That's part of what you need to
do to keep a platform running.
And that means
that that person in
certain limited circumstances
has legitimate access.
So indirectly-- you
generally don't give them
the key directly, you give them
access to a system which itself
has access to the
key, but the point is,
they're able to use it.
And so just relying
on the crypto
doesn't give you
everything you need.
You oftentimes want to go
back and look at, OK, well,
what did that person do
with that special access?
Did they use their access
properly and correctly
for the purpose that
it was intended?
So that doesn't magically
solve that problem for you.
A related problem is
processing that goes on
with data happens
in the background
or it happens in batch.
So for example,
let's say you store
a lot of data in
a database, and we
want to build an index on
that data so when you search,
you get really,
really quick results.
That needs to operate on
the data in the background,
and therefore, needs access.
So again, indirectly it
may be able to use data
that is normally encrypted.
So the crypto
doesn't protect you
intrinsically from that
code being the wrong code
or code that does something
inappropriate, so you
need other security mechanisms.
So as I was saying
before, we've actually
built stuff which makes
sure that, for things that
touch sensitive data
in context like that,
it's possible to tie it all
the way back to the [INAUDIBLE]
source code that that binary
came from, like the indexing
code in this case,
and it uses, actually,
a secure build in
release pipeline
so we can actually say, yeah,
only that indexing code ever
touched this piece of data.
And there's a variety of
other mechanisms that we use.
We actually have a
hardened platform
that goes all the way from
we do supply chain management
and we build our bios.
We do all kinds of
stuff, which hopefully we
can talk about in a future
episode in a lot more detail.
But just want to give
a little bit of context
on well, what does
encryption buy you?
And coming back to
the point of what's
the deal with key management?
Like, why is this hard?
Well, a lot of
crypto boils down to
not just is the crypto strong,
but who can access the key?
And I think an interesting
physical analogy
is let's say that you made a
car with an unbreakable lock.
So unless you had a
key that fit that lock,
there's just no way to
get in that car, right?
So that's the equivalent
of really strong crypto.
So if you were to use something
like that, you [INAUDIBLE]
really, really sure you never
locked your key in the car
because if you did,
you would just have
to send the car to be crushed.
That would be it for the car.
You would lose it.
And so that's the
same kind of thing
that you do if you
manage your own keys,
is you need to make
sure you never lose it.
And you also need
to make sure if you
make a copy because
someone else needs
to get in there once in a
while, that that copy doesn't
hang around.
And that's challenging, too.
And so in the case
of cars, of course,
like we make a different
security usability trade-off,
right?
We make sure it's not too hard
to get in so you can still call
AAA if your car breaks down.
In the case of sensitive
data, what you really want
is strong access controls.
You want to make sure that only
the appropriate [INAUDIBLE]
systems can access data
at the appropriate times.
And crypto is one tool
we use to do this,
and we try to make it as
easy as possible for people
by taking care of all
those details around well,
who gets the keys
when, and how do we
pull them back, and
so forth, so that you
don't have to do it yourself.
MARK: So as a Googler, I guess,
then, it means so I can't just
go into the Cloud Platform
stuff and be like,
oh, I'm just going
to grab your data,
because I've got no access
to any of those keys,
even if I could somehow
get into that stuff.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
UMESH: That's right, Yeah.
We do try to maintain
really tight access controls
on the data.
And we have audit logging
for when people ever
need to access the data,
which, again, is not common.
And we also maintain
a separation
of administrative domains
between the people
that maintain the key
management service, which
maintains the encryption
keys, and the people that
maintain, like, the
application code
or the other infrastructure.
So that kind of helps
mitigate our risk, as well.
FRANCESC: Very interesting.
That really sounds
like managing keys
is such a complicated thing that
the fact that Google is doing
it instead of having you
as an application developer
to take care of that--
UMESH: Yeah, no one
should want to do that.
FRANCESC: I'm at least very
happy I don't have to do that.
MARK: I've had to
work on applications
that did that stuff, and
it is really, really hard
to get it right.
And this is what I
spend my time doing.
So I think that
should definitely
be kind of like your
second option, let's say.
FRANCESC: Nice.
So we're kind of
running out of time,
but there was one
more topic that I
would like to mention just
because it's so fancy,
and it especially has a
very fancy name, which
is homomorphic encryption.
Could you tell us a
little bit about it?
Why is it cool?
Why do people care about it?
UMESH: Sure.
Homomorphic encryption is
one of the more amazing
theoretical advances in the
history of cryptography.
One of the things
that's challenging
about working with
encrypted data
is that if you use what's
called symmetric encryption,
it's really like, if you have
the key you can see the data,
and if you don't have the
key, you can't see the data.
And that makes it
really difficult
to do computations
between multiple parties
which don't fully trust each
other, because if you both have
the key, then you kind
of do have to fully trust
each other because you
can see all the data,
and if neither of
you has the key,
then you can't really do
anything interesting, right?
So people for a long time
have wanted this ability
to do what's called secure
multiparty computation,
or kind of like
private computation
that can be done across
different parties.
And basically, what homomorphic
encryption is about is saying,
actually, there is
a way to encrypt
data that allows you
to compute functions
on the encrypted data.
So it, actually, in an
interesting way kind
of calls back
something I mentioned
earlier, which is it's possible
to encrypt stuff which you
can't tell what it is, but
still manipulate it in a way
that the result is predictable
with respect to the original.
Fully homomorphic encryption--
the big advance there was it
lets you compute, like,
any function in principle
on the encrypted
data, which means
you could in theory do any
computation at all just
on the encrypted data.
Now, all that said,
despite the amazingness
of the theoretical
advance, we're still,
I think it's fair to
say, quite a ways from it
being really practical and
useful for most applications.
Part of the reason for that
is that it's really slow.
This is as of at
least maybe 4 years
ago or so when we looked
at a very rough estimate
of how much slower
would Google search be
if we had to do it using
this fully homomorphic thing?
I think the answer was roughly
a billion times slower.
FRANCESC: That's OK.
MARK: I'd wait.
I'd wait.
That'd be fine.
UMESH: So it's, like,
slightly slower than normal.
FRANCESC: Slightly slower.
UMESH: So that's not
necessarily going
to be the first application.
However, there are some
specialized scenarios
where there's not a ton of
data, where you're not really
latency sensitive, and where you
do have this scenario where you
want two parties-- they want
to be able to compute something
together, but they don't fully
trust each other to actually
be able to use this technology.
And we actually do have
some experimental projects
which do stuff like that.
A good example of the kind
of [INAUDIBLE] with this
is what's called secure
set intersection.
That's where, like, let's say
that you have a bunch of users
and I have a bunch of users
that are doing something,
and we want to know which
of them are in common,
but neither of us wants
to reveal our full user
list to the other one.
So this would allow us
to compute something
like that, for example.
And maybe we're OK if
it takes a little while.
It's not really a big
deal it takes a while.
So along those lines,
actually, BigQuery
has built some
experimental support
for doing queries on encrypted
data, which basically lets
you upload encrypted data so
that Big Query itself can't
see it.
Yet, Big Query is able to
run some queries for you,
give you some answers
that will actually
answer your query in a
way that BigQuery never
saw either the actual
question in some cases,
with some caveats, or the data
itself, which is pretty cool.
It's not super scalable, but it
is something that is out there,
and you can actually
play with it on GitHub.
FRANCESC: Cool.
That sounds like the future.
That sounds very interesting.
MARK: Well, we're definitely
running out of time,
but just very quickly,
is there anything else
we might have missed
or you need to plug,
or resources people
should go look at?
UMESH: I think
probably the best thing
to do if you're
really interested in
this topic is to check out
the encryption white paper
that we recently put out.
It has a ton of detail
on how this stuff works.
We can also put up a link to
the encrypted BigQuery client
if you're interested
to play around
with homomorphic encryption.
And also, stay tuned
for future episodes
where we talk about a whole
bunch of other security topics.
FRANCESC: Cool.
We'll have all of those
links on the show notes,
and we'll be waiting for you to
come back to the next episodes.
All right, thanks a lot, guys.
It's been a pleasure.
MARK: Thank you so much.
Thanks again to Umesh
for joining us today.
That was a great conversation
about security-- something
I am very glad that I don't
have to worry about as much,
because that sounds
super complicated.
FRANCESC: Yeah.
It is very complicated,
and it's one
of those things where it is
cool to try to understand it
and everything, but knowing
that the responsibility
of the system is in your hands--
that is, like, no, no, no, no.
MARK: Yeah, it's totally
the double whammy.
It's super complicated, but you
do not want to get it wrong.
FRANCESC: Yeah.
So very happy with all the
content of the interview.
I learned a lot.
And I'm actually looking forward
to next episodes on security.
MARK: Yeah.
I want to hear more.
Yeah.
OK, so I think it's time to go
to the question of the week.
And as we said before,
the question of the week
is quite simple.
OK, so I have static
content-- let's say,
HTML, CSS, JavaScript--
and I want to serve it.
MARK: What do I do?
FRANCESC: What do we do?
MARK: Yeah, so I actually
brought this one up
because we recently released
a whole solution around this,
which I think is
highly extensive
and really, really cool.
So let's go through the layers,
which are really, really cool.
So say you have nothing-- don't
need to worry about anything
dynamic, everything's fine.
You can serve static
content right out
through Google Cloud Storage.
FRANCESC: Cool.
MARK: Which is cool.
So you get edge
caching, you don't
need to worry about running
up servers, nothing like that.
Very, very simple to use.
You push it up, it
stays there-- beautiful.
But it is worth noting
that if you have content
that you want served over
HTTPS, unfortunately,
Google Cloud Storage
won't help you with that,
so you're going to have to look
at one of the other options.
FRANCESC: Not yet.
I'm sure that this is something
that we will add at some point,
but it is important to take into
account that if you want HTTPS,
Google Cloud Storage is probably
not the best place to put it.
MARK: Absolutely.
So next-- OK, down
the list we go.
So we can also do stuff
on virtual machines.
So Google Compute
Engine-- you want
to install Apache, NGINX,
something like that.
What's cool about the
solution, as well,
is it shows you how to
do that, but then also
how to load balance
it, autoscale it, make
sure you can handle as much load
as is coming in at that given
point in time.
And it's got guides all the
way through that, as well.
On top of that, there
is a whole, obviously,
container solution, because
we talk about containers
all the time.
So again, the guide takes
you through that, as well--
scaling that, load balancing
that, setting up monitoring
and logging within
Container Engine,
how to do that within that
of static serving capability.
So that works really
well, as well.
And finally, if you don't
want to manage it at all,
but you need, maybe,
HTTPS, or maybe you
have some dynamic content, we
have some managed platforms
such as Google App Engine.
FRANCESC: Yeah.
And the good thing about Google
App Engine is, as we have said
before, you basically
just give us the code
and forget about it.
Everything will just
scale, handle the traffic,
however big or small
the traffic is.
And that's what we use
for the podcast, really.
MARK: Yeah, I mean, if you want
to go back to episode number 1,
we talk a lot about how we
use the App Engine to host
all the static
content for the site,
and it works fantastically.
FRANCESC: Episode number one.
MARK: Episode number one.
FRANCESC: That was
a long time ago.
So yeah, let us know if you
have any questions about how
to serve static web content.
And we'll have a
link on the show
notes to the article with
all the solutions and all
the different options, and how
to do every single one of them.
MARK: Absolutely.
So Francesc, what are you up to?
You running around
anywhere in particular?
FRANCESC: So I'm actually
planning my next trip.
It's going to be in November,
and I'm going to Brazil.
Yeah, I'm very excited.
I'm going to be
doing the opening
keynote at GopherCon, Brazil.
MARK: Nice.
FRANCESC: And I even know what
I'm going to be talking about,
which is kind of new.
And then on top
of that, I'm going
to be attending a dev fest
somewhere there in Brazil,
and there's going to
be some other events.
So I'm very excited about that.
I've never been to
Brazil, so excited.
MARK: Cool.
FRANCESC: What about you?
MARK: Next week, or actually,
when this comes out,
it'll be-- yeah, next week,
I will be at Strange Loop,
one of my favorite conferences.
FRANCESC: So jealous.
MARK: Yeah, I'm so
happy about that.
And I'll be doing a couple
little things around there.
I've got an unsession in.
I'm hoping it gets accepted.
Hopefully we'll find
out soon, as well.
So it should be lots
and lots of fun.
FRANCESC: Cool.
MARK: So thank you,
Francesc, for joining me
for yet another week
and yet another episode.
FRANCESC: Thank you, Mark.
It was a pleasure, as usual.
MARK: Yeah.
And thanks to everyone
who was listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC: Yeah, see
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]